social media is fueling a lot of that
insanity and we're seeing it spill out
beyond the digital world we're seeing it
now in fast food restaurants it's like
every single day you guys and this is
why it's playing about all the time look
what's what's his name
what's your name Alex yeah your name's
Alex and I'm gonna be talking to your
manager this guy called me sir
everywhere I go I get called Sir why
would you call a chick
and you're a liar I heard you stop
gaslighting trans people
okay wait what
did you call me sir again what was that
you said good night sir
Alex I'm gonna be talking how many times
have you seen this video you okay
remember there's the ones that hulking
dude goes into a bodega New York for
instance
remember it's man
no you don't do this to trans people
this is discrimination I didn't no this
is discrimination I'm done with it
who behaves like this who be forget the
gender identity problems for a second
who behaves like this ever
I go out in public occasionally someone
will slight me on occasion you know most
people love me but on occasion someone
will say a nasty comment or insult me or
be rude sometimes even at a fast food
joint
and you know what I do I do the same
thing that you do that every normal
person does say ah okay yeah whatever
buddy okay fine whatever you take your
hamburger and you leave
the kind of people who behave this way
are
I'm probably not allowed to say it on
YouTube so believe me if you have to
whatever
[Music]
best vegan muster with foreign policy
these days
is
to ban Tick Tock the the best well the
the Pentagon is out there they want to
to treat teach transgenderism to little
Afghani boys or I don't know what they
want to do
I think the best the best option that
they have offered is to ban Tick Tock
for which the CEO of tick tock has now
flown to the United States He is
lobbying lawmakers and he's directly
appealing to the American people to get
their lawmakers to allow Tick Tock to
remain in this country here's his
argument hi everyone it's Joe here I'm
the CEO of tick tock I'm here in
Washington DC today and uh I have some
news and updates to share with everyone
here today I'm super excited to announce
that more than 150 million Americans on
Tick Tock yeah that's the U.S coming to
tick tock to connect
create to share to learn or just to have
some fun this includes 5 million
businesses that use tick tock to reach
the customers and the majority of these
a small and medium businesses now these
numbers are amazing and I'm so thankful
to all of you and the 7 000 Tick Tock
employees in the US who are helping us
build this incredible community in
America and around the world now this
comes at the pivotal moment for us some
politicians have started talking about
banning Tech talk now this could take
Tick Tock away from all 150 million of
you I'll be testifying about Congress
later this week to share all that we're
doing to protect Americans using the app
and deliver on our mission to inspire
creativity and to bring joy and don't
threaten me with a good time take away
Tick Tock from 150 million Americans I
think a lot of people can get behind
this because we think wow more than half
the country is hooked on this stupid
Doom scrolling app that doesn't add
anything to our lives and only only
destroys our brains and our memories and
opens us up to all sorts of propaganda
and has back doors to the Chinese
Communist party yeah no thanks
a lot of people think that when you add
on to that the the
amount of time that Tick-Tock users
spend on the app
the average Twitter user depends on
which survey you're looking at the
average Twitter user spends something
like two to six minutes a day on the app
some of us spend a lot more time on the
app but but that's the average Twitter
user the average Tick Tock user spends
something like 56 minutes a day on the
app it's not even close it's so many
multiples higher or order of magnitude
higher and then some
so yeah this this represents a a threat
to the American mind
but then my question is okay we're going
to ban tick tock
what about Facebook Twitter and Google
not saying we ban all those things but I
am wondering hold on why are we so
worried about tick tock
well we're worried about Tick Tock
because it's a Chinese company okay
did was it tick tock that de-platformed
the duly elected sitting president of
the United States
was it tick tock
that interfered in the 2020 presidential
election and suppressed a new story that
was damaging to Joe Biden and suppressed
it at every single level including
private messages was it tick tock that
did that
I don't think it was Tick Tock as I as I
recall it was Twitter
and Facebook and Google
tick tock's got a bunch of problems if
the lawmakers want to ban it fine
whatever
but actually the people who benefit from
Tick Tock being banned
are Facebook and Twitter
and Google
the the very companies
that have taken so much of our political
power in so many of our rights away that
have acted in a way to dominate the
Public Square which is the political
order in a republic
in which brazenly de-platformed
conservatives and censored conservative
news stories and censored the duly
elected sitting conservative president
of the United States I've heard enough
about Tick Tock do whatever you want
with tick tock
what about those other guys
they're my main concern
and in as much as Banning Tick Tock
helps Facebook and Google and Twitter
Twitter now is owned by Elon so I'll
give it more slack but in as much as
Banning tick tock
just helps American big tech companies
which pose one of the biggest threats to
conservative political power into our
whole political order in the United
States
and I'm not for it
in as much as it helps those big tech
companies here in Silicon Valley I would
prefer that Tick Tock remain available
just to give those guys a little bit of
competition
because the next time that they move to
censor Trump or whoever the next
Republican nominee is maybe maybe that
Republican nominee will be able to find
a home on Tick Tock they seem to be
playing much more fairly with American
conservatives than than the allegedly
American businesses over in Silicon
Valley are
the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
Canada wlas a checkout for two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign